في قمه رابطه دول جنوب شرق اسيا عام 2019
رفض الرئيس الامريكي حينها دونالد ترامب
افاده مسؤول امريكيين لحضور القمه فاثر
الامر شكوكا لدى هذه الدول بشان اولويه
هذه المنطقه في الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه في
قمه هذا العام بنفسه يشارك فيها واعلن ان
الولايات المتحده ودول اسيا سترفع
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه الى مستوى الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه الشامله خطوه كهذه سبقت
اليها الصين عام 2021 ورفعت شركتها مع دول
اسيا الى شراكه استراتيجيه شامله وذاك هو
بيت القصيده
[موسيقى]
لاعاده تقييم السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه
جزءا من استرته كمح النفوذ الصينيه بدات
تنفيذ ذلك منذ الانسحاب الامريكي من
افغانستان
لاعاده توجيه البوصله نحو الصين عمدت
الاداره الامريكيه خلال في الاول من هذا
العام الى عقد قمه جمعت اول مره في واشنطن
الرئيس الامريكي بقاده دول اسيان تعهد
ايضا يومها بانفاق 150 مليون دولار
للمساعده في تحسين البنيه التحتيه وامن
دول اسيا وتنفيذ مشروعات اخرى لكن هذا
الانفاق الامريكيه يبدو اقل من الانفاق
الصيني الاكثر سخاء اذ تعاهدت بيجين في
نوفمبر من العام الماضي بتقديم مليار ونصف
الملياردولار في شكل مساعده انمائيه لدول
اسيان على مدى ثلاث سنوات
اضافه الى ذلك عزيزه الولايات المتحده
انتشارها العسكريه في منطقه المحيطين
الهادي والهندي ورفعت وتيره المناورات
العسكريه مع حلفائها هناك ولضع الخصوم
وطمئنه الحلفاء نشر الطائرات حربيه بعيده
المدى في جزيره جوان غرب المحيط الهادي
مرتين خلال هذه السنه تعول دول جنوب شرق
اسيا على دعم امريكي اكبر من مواجهه
الطموحات الصينيه
في ظل التحركات العسكريه لبيجين في بحري
جنوب وشرق الصين انها تقف امام مثلث ازمات
اقليمي ودولي شديد التوتر اضلاعه الثلاثه
هي الوضع في تايوان وتهديدات كوريا
الشماليه والحرب في اوكرانيا لذلك اكد
الرئيس الامريكي يعقب قمه اسيان في
كمبوديا على اهميه الحفاظ على السلام
والاستقرار عبر مضيق تايوان واحترام حريه
الملاحه والتحليق في بحر الشرق وجنوب
الصين وضروره حل كل النزاعات سلميه
[موسيقى]